das ist c zu der Reportage Singles mit
powerhof Partnersuche mit
Hürden danke viel viel mal für große
Interesse ich bin mega happy wie viel l
sich g wie viel Kommentar D es geh wie
viel Diskussionen und auch Kritik und
Lob ich muss aber leider auchisprechen
bevor man wi gönt
es sie de privat schrieben
protagoniste Dani
unden privat vor allem dan über Facebook
Nachrichten schrieben und es macht mich
extrem TRG sie hab also ich kan
Screenshots gesehen von den Nachrichten
und das ich kan nicht anders sagen ich
fin zum kotz was ich g hab die
Beleidigungen wo sind und das auch aufs
US und das das bodyshaming und alles W
ich in Glas
hab ist extrem respektlos dann so
zammenhalungslos einfach auf Facebook
oder Instagram oder weiß ich wo gar und
persönlich so beleidigen die Nachrichten
schriebe ich finde das hat wirklich kein
Platz
und das darf einfach nicht sie der
größte Teil von der kommentär sind aber
sehr sehr wohlwollend und schön g also
zum einen die öffentliche Kommentare
aber auch die Nachrichten W len und der
dan privat bekom sind zum allergrößte
Teil sehr sehr positiv gesie danke viel
viel mal für das es hat natürlich ein
Kritik geh und das ist ja gut so sehr
respektvolle Kritik wo man könnte drüber
diskutieren wo man einm kan Meinig stah
und genauso Komment der möchte wir jetzt
Zen und für das möchte ich ein Video
call machen mit der
Lenia l
hi Z wo bist bist dem Zimmer B Großmama
ah BTE Großmutter
wo
Stock
okay größ Teil von der kom sind ja sehr
sehr positiv oder hast
du also ich n sch die Top D Kommentar
vor also die die Kommentar wo meist
likes be und die sind der Niederhaus
schriebt sehr sympathisch sind bauen die
Jungen haben es wirklich nicht leicht
dann der borstig Wolf schribt herrliche
junge Menschen ich wünsche allen dass
sie ihr Glück finden und der dritte
Kommentar vom half schribt wunderbare
Reportage holt mich immer wieder auf dem
Boden zurück haben auch Bauern in
unserer Familie ein Knochenjob wünsche
den Singles tolle Partnerschaften für
die Zukunft und viel Lebensfreude h du
rückmal et
persönlich be dir g also ich so cool du
bist im Fernseh gar nicht du das gemacht
heso h nie ges und ja
ja ke positive und du hast mir noch
gescheben du hast sehr viel sehr viel
aufage auf
Instagram
ja
ich a
fr
a und alle a
was für was für
fürfrage also aus mögliche also s
mehrhelich
man
und mega jung ir so 15 gefüht bis zu 40
50 also wir durch die Blume aus
mlich
büar wirklich krass
cool
g also persönlich aber so ja cool dass
das gemacht und me
sympathisch
meemacht also positiv für
dich ja Lust paar
Komment also der Gregor
wer will im Jahr 2023 z.B einem Zimmer
im Elterhaus wohnen und die Frau muss
noch gratis Arbeiten diewartungshalten
scheint völlig unvernünftig was sag zu
wenn jetzt l sag hey dass das nicht zcht
ist so wie du W
wohne das Problem also ganzlich ich w so
wohne wenn ich w und ich muss mit dem
ich w und andere wenn sie nicht
so sichuber also W und so woh wie sie
w und das
ist
ja zi Generation und das finde ich
[Musik]
Jam
wirklich
W ein witer Kommentar ich vom irus Virus
hatte Erft würden die beiden Dani und
Lenia ihren Hof komplett aufgeben wenn
Sie einen Partner finden würden aber auf
dessen Hof arbeiten sollten und wenn
nein wieso
nicht also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich würde das
machen wenn Hof h wo für mich machbar
ist also zum und wenn das TR ist und sch
und sch ganz viel Geld und so investiert
wde ich das sofort machen mir drum
zum Betrieb
schaff das machen
ich das W wie W wie schön wenn den
Hof schön W für die Elter für die
Großelter und für Tradition und und
binig mit hast ja auch gesagt
aber wenn wenn jetzt
eine dich mit S große liederschaft
wirtecken für Sie Hof und sie la dann W
offen so ich das verstanden ja
ja Kommentar ist vom
lmjt2 WJ auf jeden Fall mal tinder
probierere verli nicht
Verl esfah
machen
für michar die
FR ich mus das bin ich
definitiv ja
und das war das them W
50 kein Thema ich so schlechte
ERF ich kan
nein g Thema so dating Apps Online
Dating ne nicht gar
nicht h wahrscheinlich auch müss ich
wahrscheinlich Radios extrem groß auf
den App so Radius V
l km und du h so
viel Radius
oder und die kan bist
mit das nicht so spannend für
oder größere
Partys wo du n kan oder
nicht oder
ja
einf
Kommentar wie soll man sich den auf die
Beziehung und das Miteinander
konzentrieren wenn man schonch Zeit
entscheiden müsste ob man zusammen in
einen
Landwirtschaftsbetrieb einzieht und den
führt ein ewiges Abwegen und rationales
Denken das Herz hat da kaum mehr Platz
zum etwas
sagen
plat das es ist mir
Frage das
Vorst
irgendwientscheid ich ke einach D ich ma
s ich bra
ein ja es muss wirklich
stimmen dan Gag ich
s ich s dann Hochzeit
V filenn dann
so aber ich muss es plus mitbringen kann
ich bei dir
auf
be mir ja so follow up machen wenn so ja
also danke für
mal
geht c c tschüss ich hab vorher mit Dan
telefoniert er n stell zu Kommentar ich
begrief das aufgrund von den unschöne
Kommentar und Nachricht W hat und drum
wde ich wiar mit das paar allgemeine
Kommentar wo in sind wo zum Teil auch an
mich gerichtet sind und ein Thema wo
viele beschäftigt hat ich Partnerin oder
ein Partner auf dem Betrieb astelle Ja
oder Nein der ur z.B schribt die
Partnerin oder Frau anstellen ja
natürlich hat doch mit Wertschätzung zu
tun ich kann noch bit wi noch
recherchiert und auch mit dem
landfrauverband noch geredet und sie
ganze Liste geschckt vor so Vorteil Pros
wieo Partnerin od Partner die Stelle und
eine von der genante pünkte genau die
wertschätzig also das Frauen die
wertchätz BEK dass ihre Arbeit auchis
wert hat dann ein wi Kommentar no V John
Peters er seid tolle Reportage Frage zur
Anstellung von Partnerinnen wie kann das
finanziell nicht funktionieren den Lohn
kann man ja auch wieder für das
gemeinsame Leben verwenden der ist nicht
einfach weg vom hofbudget das einzige
was temporär Weg ist vom Hof sind die
Lohn Nebenkosten vorzeuge etc aber das
ist ja gerade der springende Punkt am
ganzen ich muss sagen das ganze ist
bitel kompliziert ich kann recherchiert
was dann Nachteil sie vom vom astelle
und ist so dass wenn man wenn beide
selbständig sind also er ist gelernte
Landwirt und tut s die Frau nichtstellen
sondern sie ist Aal gewerbend dann kan
man der Umsatz einfach Split und dann g
nicht verloren vor dem vor dem Geld und
beide benefit dass sie vorsorg dass sie
Arbeitslose Geld be etc wenn er jetzt
aber der Landwirt ist und sie astellt
also auf sie im Betrieb astellt dann
gibt bit mehr wie der AHV wo dann wir
verloren gönt aber der landfverband SE
ganz klar den Vorteil W man hat ist das
Bit Geld wo man verlt al meh hat ist wie
vergich s sie aber W mit Dan
und hat das B oder die meh V Bürokratie
wo man auch hat dass
dasure und B Grund das n ma oder eben
nicht ma und wenn ihr jetzt Kommentar
oder z report dann schrieb es mir doch
der
Kommentarspalte ich würde sehr
gern